[Music]
there is no one definition for a
pandemic the World Health Organization
scrapped its criteria 10 years ago after
the h1n1 outbreak now it's more
subjective the w-h-o says it's when a
new disease spreads easily from person
to person around the world now in more
than 50 countries about a quarter of all
nations coronavirus or covered 19
certainly global and can spread from
person to person with more than 82,000
infections in less than two months yet
the w-h-o says it still doesn't meet the
standard for a pandemic our message
continues to be that this virus has
pandemic potential no country should
assume it won't get cases that could be
a fatal mistake and quite literally this
virus does not respect borders
the w-h-o says countries should be in a
phase of preparedness for a possible
pandemic if one was declared governments
would have to roll out a full-scale
response with mobilization done to local
level and distribution of personal
protective equipment antivirals and
other medical supplies it's costly and
in 2009 the last time the w-h-o declared
a pandemic some countries criticized the
move for burdening them unnecessarily
w-h-o and others don't like to use the
word pandemic but by the classical
definition we're really teetering very
very close to that because there are a
number of countries outside of China
that do have considerable number of
cases the costs of a moderate to severe
pandemic are high the World Bank puts it
at nearly five hundred and seventy
billion dollars even without meeting the
threshold coronavirus has shaken
financial markets but the human cost is
still low relative to pass pandemics the
1918 Spanish flu killed 50 million
people and infected one third of the
world's population
the most recent pandemic swine flu in
2009 killed up to five hundred and
seventy five thousand people coronavirus
sits at 0.5% of that the w-h-o hoping it
levels off and it doesn't have to
declare a pandemic shallow Bellis al
jazeera